that would want him gone and i think
that's why it's getting so
visceral and nasty right at this moment
because it's always like this in the
final tussles
and we had a brief chat with rory
stewart a former conservative leadership
candidate who said any other leader
would resign but we're not talking about
any other leader are we we're talking
about boris johnson and when faced with
the double whammy as you said of the
of his chancellor and his health
secretary going
just replaced them and moved on i mean
yes there's been resignations letters of
no confidence since then
but your gut feeling beth
could we be where we've been before we
think this may be the end and then he
comes out the other side well i i think
why is this different i think it's fair
to say
that what he has made very clear today
in his performance at prime minister's
questions and then the statements that
downing street made after uh pmq's that
he doesn't intend to resign he has said
bring on the confidence vote i won't uh
resign you're going to have to force
you're going to have to vote me out and
he will be making the calculation that
it might be the case that enough mps
support him that he survives another
confidence vote that i think is mentally
where he is now but what you're seeing
happening
is that even if he wants that to be that
the case and he's willing that to be the
case loyal cabinet ministers are saying
the game's up you've got michael gove
privately saying come on the game's up
don't kind of put me in a position i
imagine i don't know what the
conversation was but where i will resign
too so the pressure on him is just
building and building and building and
then it's a question of whether
he decides or his advice and takes the
advice that it's easier just to resign
but but everything that boris johnson
has said is he will fight on so it might
not
be as quick as perhaps some people
expect it might have to come down to
a confidence vote
and then a decision over his future but
i think
if you just stand back a second from the
kind of running drama of the day as
we've watched this this snowball build
and build until an avalanche for him
whatever happens now
his party is ungovernable as him as
prime minister he's had the resignation
of 27
people from his government beth i'm just
going to interrupt you because the
liaison committee is now underway
about
what we can talk about and not talk
about as colleagues know i'm aware i'm
on the
privileges committee and colleagues will
be aware that the house has referred
the question of whether or not the prime
minister's answer about the events in
number 10 and the cabinet office during
lockdown amounted to misleading the
house
referred that has referred that to the
privileges committee
just as we would not refer to something
which was sub-judicey it would be wrong
to go into detail about a matter which
the house has referred elsewhere for
examination and i very much wanted
our colleagues and the prime minister
and the public to understand that we
have to operate under that constraint
and i remind colleagues that the speaker
and his deputies have pulled people up
about this in the chamber
we should not be undermining the process
the house has itself has set in place
there is of course no difficulty in
raising any other matter
and the prime minister's prime minister
i have no wish to constrain anything
that you wish to say in this committee
but i will have to pull you up if you
stray into the privileges committee
agreement thank you
prime minister it was it is our
intention
to
start with the great issues facing the
nation
um
um and to move to the question of um
integrity and politics and related
matters towards the end of the session
um unless you wanted to dispose of those
matters immediately first
uh i'm i'll be better at your committee
i'll be i'll be guided right very good
um
i'm afraid i will pull you up if your
answers are pressing on time
um so that we can do with that latter
topic fully and properly at the end
and if your answers are too long i'm
afraid we will just detain you until we
have completed your business
so um every incentive for you to be as
crisp as possible and that goes for the
questions as well colleagues
we will start on the topic of ukraine
with the chair of the foreign affairs
committee
the alliance that has been brought
together
to dissuade russia from further actions
and indeed to push russia out of donetsk
in the hands
has clearly got a window of opportunity
before the winter starts to bite and the
coalition starts to fracture as energy
prices in europe rise and homes across
our country start to suffer
are you able to concentrate on building
that alliance at the moment
yes and uh thanks tom the if you look at
what the uk
done over the last
couple of weeks
i think that the
efforts of uk diplomacy
uk
strategist security armed forces have
been very considerable and the
g7 outcomes were at the upper end of
expectations nato uh
certainly again probably both exceeded
expectations in the
um the level of of unity
and uh virtually every country around
the table in nato
determined to
help president zolensky in in that
window of opportunity that you described
and you're seeing of course food prices
rise around the world as the ports of
odessa are closed mariopol and so on
occupied what are you doing to make sure
that the food is getting out from the
black sea that such wheat is available
is able to get out how are you
supporting the united nations and what
are you doing to prepare those states
including the middle east and of course
in africa who are facing enormous food
poverty and the possibility of migration
and the pressures that that will cause
so first of all on the
uh the
grain that's being held hostage in
odessa uh we're working with the with un
secretary general antonio guterres uh
who's who's leading the negotiations the
turks are clearly crucial uh they they
hold the waters uh what the uk is
offering
is
uh both demining capabilities
including uh remote demining
capabilities which were
good at
and the insurance of the
vessels that might be used to ferry the
the grain out down uh out from the out
through the boss for us uh we're also
uh
because
we're looking at other routes in
addition to uh convoys through the
bosphorus
we're also doing what we can to
help a smaller uh packets of uh of grain
uh go through land routes or indeed up
up the river danube uh and out that way
and uh were spending some money on
upgrading the railways to uh to that end
and you're starting to see some some
growing quantities of grain coming out
uh not via the black sea but by uh but
overland and on the rivers now we're
seeing as you know we're seeing enormous
pressure on
the weaponry that goes into ukraine
we're seeing a lot of promises and sadly
from many countries fewer deliveries
than are promised
what are you doing to increase the
production and cooperation between
armament companies around europe and
around the united states
and canada to increase the supply the uk
led the way in
uh inaugurating the ramstein uh
conferences which brought countries
together to supply a weaponry to
to ukraine and uh and
though the americans are now very much
in the lead on that and are certainly
providing uh the the bulk of what's
going in
uh and we'll be doing more in august as
a copenhagen conference as i'm sure you
know another another military uh donor
conference
there there is a
community the supplies continue to
uh to go in
the ukrainians are steadily getting the
kind of kit that they
that they need if they're going to repel
expel the russians from where where they
are but it's also very important that
they are trained to use
uh the
the mlrs the multi-multi-launch rocket
systems uh effectively so that uh you
know very expensive weaponry is is put
to good use now you've ex your foreign
secretary forgive me has explained that
uh victory in ukraine means taking back
every single square inch of ukrainian
soil including crimea what's your view
of victory um we can't be more ukrainian
than the ukrainians uh that's for for
them to decide that president zolensky
has set out his uh his ambitions uh it
will ultimately be for him to decide
what uh the terms that he wants but he's
been very clear that he would like to
return at least to the status quo auntie
uh february the 24th
and so what do you what your view of
what victory for us should look like i
think that
that's
i think the victory for uh for the
ukrainians would be
a result that uh the ukrainian people uh
feel uh is the right one and at the
moment i think i'm right in saying that
90 or more of ukrainians believe
passionately that there should be no
deal that involves land for peace and
they want the russians expelled from
every part of the territory uh that
putin has invaded are you confident of
holding the nato agreement together and
or rather the european and american
agreements together in making sure that
coalition
sustains the ukrainians even when the
winter prices start to bite i think what
was notable at
madrid was how
uh anxiety is about the friability of
the coalition uh were proved to be
unfounded and that's because the logic
of the situation simply demands
international unity there's no other
solution there's no deal on offer even
if the ukrainians wanted to do a deal
of land for peace putin isn't offering
any such deal he still remains utterly
maximalist in his objectives and that's
why
we have to continue to support zolensky
in the way that we are and that's
accepted around the table and part of
your commitment to sustaining uh
ukrainian operations and indeed wider
british military operations your
increase to two and a half percent given
that the
various international organizations and
indeed our own statistical agencies do
not foresee any growth in the uk economy
in the coming years who are you going to
take the money off in order to increase
the defense budget uh well uh i'm i'm
not certain i agree with you your
premise about the uh the growth of the
uk economy in the in the coming years i
think if you look at the both i'm sure
we'll come to this in
in in later sections but in both the uh
imf and the oecd see us uh going back to
at or near the top of the
of the growth league
2.5 is a logic it's just a it's just a
prediction it's it's based on uh the i
think reasonable assumption that we are
going to
have to continue with the investments
that we're making in the future combat
aircraft system and the and the orcas
uh
agreements with the australians and the
americans these are very these are very
big projects and
uh they'll they'll they'll be expensive
but they're the right things for the
country and so the last question from me
will be on sweden and finland clearly
their membership of nato is an extremely
important event not just for them for
all of us
what are the implications for the
guardian of the high north and
particularly the
integrity of the united kingdom and
scotland as part of that
in
the alliance and what are the
commitments that the uk is willing to
make to uh increase cooperation with
sweden and finland not just in
military supplies but also in training
yeah we thank you we already do a lot of
uh cooperating with the joint
expeditionary uh force that jeff as you
know is up there in the in the high
north uh the the addition of finland and
sweden is a great moment for uh the
alliance i think it will strengthen uh
the alliance and you know it tells you
all you need to know about uh putin and
his aggression that countries as
peaceable as uh sweden and finland have
decided to join nato
thank you chair uh prime minister good
to see you uh again we're establishing
that the world is getting more dangerous
the next decade is going to be very
bumpy indeed i want to focus on uk
defense capabilities despite the
injection of 24 billion pounds the
integrated view has seen a tilt towards
cyber in space which is welcome but it's
come at the expense of cuts to all three
conventional services at your last
appearance here prior to the russian
invasion you boldly stated that tanks
are not the answer to the defense of
ukraine but the old context concepts of
tank battles on the european land mass
are over
prime minister do you now recognize the
value of tanks as part of our landfall
warfare mix and plans to reduce our tank
numbers now need to be reviewed uh i
thank thank you very much tobias i think
that uh when you when when you certainly
i think that it's important for the uk
uh to have
uh
tanks but uh i think for the ukrainian
purposes uh even more valuable were
anti-tank weapons and if you look at
what really changed the uh course of the
first few weeks of the war it was the
javelins it was the enlaws in particular
and the javelins
that were used to destroy the tanks and
ready to make make russia's tank warfare
extremely difficult and you'll have seen
exactly what happened
that's understood and i don't disagree
with that what i'm trying to stress at
is that the defense budget it will
actually go down by a billion pounds in
2023 24 according to library
figures and you mentioned end laws we
have stockpiles which are being depleted
we're short of deep fire capabilities uh
rocket artillery air defense and indeed
hypersonics as well this is where the
character of conflict
is moving we need to invest more
including in those tanks which we're
cutting by a third and indeed our
warrior fighting vehicles we have no
capability to do dismounted infantry
because we're actually cutting the
entire warrior fleet could i beg with
the prime minister to reconsider the
army numbers if there's one thing he
could take away from here with his new
chancellor to look at securing 40
million pounds required to reverse the
cuts uh in our army manpower
thanks i just i just want to stress that
the
uh you know we we value uh immensely the
the
armed forces in the sense we value the
numbers of troops uh if you include the
reserves there are in fact over a
hundred
thousand so seventy three thousand in
the regular army across thirty thousand
uh reserves uh but i i think it's also
very important that you know i heard of
all the points that people like general
sanders have made
but the important thing is
to have the best possible equipment
for those uh those those troops and
that's what we're doing well let's look
at that equipment because in the army i
just said we're losing a third of our
tanks we're losing our warrior fighting
vehicles we're decimating our tracked
land warfare capability in the raf we're
down from 36 squadrons during the gulf
war to just six today we're losing all
our hercules heavy lift we're losing
we only have 48 of the 138 f-35s we're
losing uh two of the e-7 i-star aircraft
that are so critical to work with the
f-35s and in the navy in 1990s during
the cold war we had 13 destroyers 35
frigates and we're down to just
18. we are hollowing out
all our armed services at the very time
that as you mentioned the head of the
army is saying we face in 1937 moment
this is just the time to be investing
their wrong forces uh not uh depleting
capability well i agree with that but
that's why we're spending uh 24 billion
uh over the next uh four years it's the
biggest increase since the end of the of
the cold war and i think that money is
being is being wisely spent
you talk about it already it's gone that
you well it's over it's over the the
next four years it's gone in to invest
into paying for the replacement of the
vanguard submarines the money didn't
even hit the sides that's where it was
needed to make sure that program allowed
us to continue our nuclear deterrent
i understand but you know we're we're
also committed as i said earlier on to
a number of uh
massive projects you mentioned heavy
lift aircraft actually if you uh if you
look at what the uk has it's i think
we're still by far the biggest uh
possessor of heavy lift aircraft in uh
in europe um
[Music]
on ships uh where we've got a very
active
shipbuilding program you know tobias i
take your point about tanks again humbly
and sincerely and you know i i will i
will take it away and look at it and
look at the armament personnel carries
the armored vehicles
they have been useful uh to the
ukrainians uh particularly the armored
uh the armored vehicles uh but
uh
you know the committee should be in no
doubt we're investing massively in
defense i i
i hear what you say but i mean you're
you're a classicist you know your
response is to date make me feel like um
homer's cassandra i i say to you we must
prepare for the storm clouds that are
coming over the horizon and you don't
seem to believe me i say we can't afford
these troop cuts uh in our in our army
numbers but you don't believe me and i
say that we need to reverse these cuts
in our land warfare systems our ships
and indeed our planes and you still
don't believe me and there is a change
of foot we are our history and the
turning point in our history and we need
to prepare for what is coming over the
horizon britain must play its path there
is a gap in leadership in europe and i
want britain to assume that role we can
only do so
if we prepare today and advance our
defense question do you think you should
have been uh later to listen i wasn't
invited to the well
one day one day one day
to listen to what the other countries
say about the uk contribution and the uh
indispensability of uh uk armed forces
our contribution to uh to nato's new
force model uh the role that we uh we
play we're the second biggest spendo uh
in nato but a massive contributor to all
the joint operations and i think jen
stoltenberg the secretary general uh
would uh would testify that and when you
say
i don't believe that's not true i do
understand the need for
uh more spending on defense it has to be
balanced against other priorities and it
is going on then reverse those troop
numbers okay
um can i just press one matter related
to this
we have given away our training stocks
of end law of
mlrs and other munitions to the
ukrainians
what are we doing to galvanize the
supply chain back to a wartime
capability that will provide resilience
of stocks because at the moment we
simply can't replace those stocks well
thank you but actually if you look at
what's happening in belfast they they
are they're making a lot of animals
they're not replacing as fast as we're
giving them away that is a fact that is
true they take a while tonight but we're
replacing them but i mean this goes to
the heart of the integrated review which
was very good on analysis
and
uh requirement but very there are only
two pages on the implementation
what are we going to do to make sure
that we implement the defense
integration review so that we actually
have the capability ready when we need
it because at the moment we don't
we're supplying a huge amount of
capability uh i accept the uh the view
that we need to to modernize and and do
more and uh more in-laws are uh
certainly running off the production
line at tarle i think it's tallest in in
belfast is it time to quickly uh is it
time to uh review aspects of the
integrated review
i think the integrated review has stood
the test of time well
uh and you know i'm happy to take it
around later um
um angus mcneil thank you very much mr
chairman um prime minister about four
years ago just now i was comparing a
predecessor to gloria gaynor
because she will survive
and that very moment there was uh
perhaps a young locket var type making
his resignation statement in the house
of commons in that moment can you
remember who that was
um
mr mcneil i i you have to you know you i
was just saying
that
you're a bit of a trendsetter yes yes
yes um but what
it seems from the rumors i'm hearing
from conservative mps that you're beyond
gloria gaynor you're more than paul
young and you want to tear the playhouse
down and the warning they're getting is
if it's a sure destruction of the prime
minister you might make it mutual uh you
might call a general election of a cull
of two dnp something of course they'll
be very welcome in many sites but the
point of clarification and disagreement
that some of us have had in light of
powers have been taken away from the
fixed 10 parliament act do you need the
permission of the queen or do you just
need to inform the queen to hold an
election i i i really
don't think that uh anybody in this
country wants politicians to be engaged
in uh electioneering uh now
and i think that we need to get on with
serving the uh serving our voters and uh
dealing with the issues that they care
about so your nearly back benches are
okay um
interestingly we've had some difficulty
in the national international trade
committee with craig and the triggering
of the
process uh to bring about uh this and
you're gonna notice with this um
in parliament we look for an extension
of crack i also want to put it in prime
minister you know brexit is a five
percent damage to gdp and these trade
agreements you're signing up to are a
minor part i mean the 0.08 percent of
gdp is equivalent to going out
and
losing 500 pounds and coming back with
eight pounds of two pounds it could be
in the case of new zealand and thinking
you've done well
it's a brexit process and the trade
agreement process good for the economy
uh given what your own figures
are saying
uh yes i i think that they are and so if
you lose 500 pounds
you'll tell us all you're having a good
day i don't i you know
it was the ability to set our own uh
medicines policy that enabled us to uh
come out of the
uh
to vaccinate everybody
you get the question yes so so
to your point uh mr mcneil about the
economic benefits just you know just one
in addition to the reports free trade
deals the the ability to vary regulation
or westminster i would point out that by
being able to vaccinate faster uh than
uh a lot of other i think virtually
every other european um
which was a considerable economic
question not a vaccine's question
if you can't see the difference between
500 pounds take away 8 pounds and note
that he's out of pocket we have to leave
that there and the public can make up
their own mind about the prime minister
um
prime minister um something else that's
concerning many of my constituents is
egnos you might not know that it's a
european
geostationary navigational overlay
system it's a 3d system for aircraft in
the air the uk is only g20 country
without such a facility it's affecting
the training of pilots as well will you
get the uk back into egnos quickly or
have us an equivalent 3g
3g navigation system there in place soon
it's required uh well thank you that
that is a very interesting suggestion
i'll have a look at that we do we we do
have uh a a pioneering uh low earth
orbit uh system of satellites called one
web as as i'm sure you know but yeah
yeah so we used to aircraft at the
moment i did it
you're a fan of imperial uh system you
want to have imperial measures
do you think people if people want to
have them uh i don't think that they use
the system i mean how many owns is that
an opponent i'm not gonna i'm i'm afraid
i was i was brought up in the yeah i've
got a bit i would say you don't know how
many ages that in opponent
the basics of the imperial thing i think
there are
16 ounces right now we can't
do metric as well
so the prime minister uk is more adept
in the metric system excellence
i can tell you what i can i i think of
my weight in stone how about that okay
thank you very much
and probably put your mind at rest i
mean i've heard mention of uh sweden
finland and scotland uh i've no
questions to ask about independence
of scotland it's not a matter for you
it's a matter for the people of scotland
it will be decided in scotland
and i think uh prime minister uh that's
about all that we need to discuss uh at
the moment thank you mr chair
thank you mr mcneil uh
so robert goodwill
deferra
um i'd like to bring us back to the
topic of food security both globally and
nationally in globally it's a matter
whether people eat or starve nationally
it's having a major impact on the cost
of living crisis
and i wonder if we are underestimating
the
ease at which we can actually bring
wheat supplies and sunflower supplies
out of ukraine given the change of gauge
if the railway lines into poland given
the the way that the loading equipment
in odessa could be damaged by missiles
is it
really only realistic possibility if
there were a cease-fire and as long as
conflict is going on is there really a
possibility we can get those supplies
out well
what's actually
i mean what's happening is that the the
monthly uh consignments of grain out of
a debts that are starting to go up
um
it should be about five million tons a
month i think that it's
the most recent because i thought for
june i think is running about 2.75
million
tonnes so it's not nothing uh you can
get it out uh not just by
the seas as i was saying earlier on uh
but by uh by land routes as well uh i
think if the risk is if you
and i think what the ukrainians are
worried about is that if they negotiate
a deal with putin uh to uh get the to
get him to open up the black sea he will
demand the lifting of sanctions in an
unacceptable way
coming close to home the government
published its food strategy a couple
weeks ago which i think was widely
welcomed
uh one aspect of that was was having
more food from our own resources you
know we're self-sufficient in liquid
milk but about 75
of the food that we can produce here
climatically is produced here
do you think given the global situation
we should revisit
things like rewiring putting solar farms
on arable land or planting of trees we
should concentrate on improving food
production here at home
i i look i i i share that enthusiasm and
the
the food strategy that we uh
launched a few weeks ago certainly puts
our own domestic production at the heart
of what we're trying to do we have uh i
think 74
uh self-sufficiency but
there's a massive opportunity it affects
our affects our uh our balance of trade
um personally i would like to see many
more uh solar panels on uh on roofs than
in what could be otherwise productive
fields and i think we need to think
about sometimes about the uh the the
fiscal incentives that we offer
and finally one of the key
inputs into agriculture in our country
is nitrogen fertilizer we have a one
plant now operating at billingham the
plant in cheshire has been closed and i
think the owners are looking for buyers
is the government aware of what it can
do to try and get that plant operational
again is there any assistance that might
be available to possible buyers because
you know we'll be once again reliant on
imports of a product which
internationally is in very short supply
yeah so thank you because this is a
massive issue for for farmers uh we're
not sufficiently self-reliant in
in fertilizer
we've had the fertilizer round table
recently and and tried to
see what we can do to to help
trying to get alternatives but you know
clearly that's not all doesn't always
work not uh not as effective uh we need
to we need to make much more fertilizer
domestic i had to say i have to say one
of the reasons
uh why the the global south is suffering
so much at the moment is also shortage
of
fertilizer and there are far too few
african fertilizer uh plants and we
should we should be doing what we can uh
to help build fertilizer resilience
around around the world they are really
really feeling in there right now so
have there been any conversations with
prospective buyers of the plant in
cheshire you know i i i can't tell you
about uh about prospective buyers of
that of that plant but we're certainly
concerned about you know the there is a
single plant left
as you say and that makes us uh that
puts a lot of pressure on that plant
thank you very much um mr elwood you
want to catch my eye very briefly for a
one-liner on the ukraine grain we're
recognized thank you chair we recognize
the importance of getting grain out of
ukraine it's it's uh ground zero when it
comes to feeding not just europe but
also africa could i invite the prime
minister i think there's an opportunity
for british leadership to take this to
the un general assembly it's something
i've raised with you before sir yes and
to see whether we can get those
two-thirds votes to turn the port into
humanitarian safe haven that will then
allow or facilitate the starting point
of getting that grain out in those ships
it's the ships that we need to get out
that's the scale of exports that are
required if we're to affect the cost of
prime ministers here prime minister
so thank you i i don't disagree at all
the question is is could there be could
you get the russians to uh to do it and
and sadly um as you know tobias in the
in the even in the un general uh
assembly uh although we got a great vote
for um
uh
for the initial condemnation of the
invasion
of russia and china are very influential
dame diana home affairs
prime minister a few weeks ago i met a
group of ukrainian mps who had travelled
to the uk via the republic of ireland
like every other country the republic of
ireland in europe doesn't require a visa
they then traveled up through the common
trouble area they didn't have anything
checked
and they were raising with me whether
it was a sensible decision to allow such
a bureaucratic visa system for
ukrainians fleeing ukraine
was a sensible use of resources and
as we know has compromised the capacity
of the home office what do you say to
that
i i hear you uh loud and clear uh um
i think that
um
the argument that's been put to me is
two things first of all uh we we've got
to be careful that uh we we are able to
screen people properly and these people
are coming up through the common travel
area there's no screening
and i accept that and i accept the
limitations of
screening but on the other hand uh
you've got to look at the
um
the what we what we've done so far 135
000 visas have been issued um
and i think that the record is is
getting better and better the uk is
hosting a lot of ukrainians and you
should be very proud of that so perhaps
i'll come on to the problems with the
home office which uh as i've just
alluded to the capacity issues of the
home office when they designed a whole
new visa system why is it that british
people are waiting so long to get their
passports when we all knew there was
going to be a surge in passport
applications after coving with people
wanting to travel
have family holidays uh get married
abroad all of those things why is it
that we've ended up with people waiting
so long and having to spend so much time
and money to get a passport well i i it
is very frustrating and i share
everybody's
frustration i think that the answer is
that uh the the demand has been very big
because people are uh
very keen to go on holiday and we rushed
people into the uh the passport
office and the numbers are the numbers
are starting to improve i think from
memory 91
uh get uh their uh their passport within
four to six weeks
well the standard that the home office
is supposed to operate on is three weeks
it's now ten weeks when will it go back
down to three weeks well i i i don't
know when it goes back down to three
weeks but i think but what i have in my
head is that 91 percent get their their
passport within uh within four to six
weeks i'd urge everybody who's seen keep
going away uh you know four to six weeks
from now uh and hasn't got a passport to
get a passport okay so the bread and
butter issues just aren't being looked
at by the home office and dealt with in
a in a very uh a good way can i just ask
you why is it your government has now
got a backlog of 89 000 asylum claims
that they haven't decided
why why has that happened well the the
the uk has historically had
very large numbers of
silent claims and i i seem to remember
that there were many many uh uh
thousands of asylum claims uh
correct understand
decided when the uh when the last labor
government left off no prime minister
the the asylum claims in this country
have remained fairly steady in the last
few years so your home office has built
up a backlog of nearly 90 000 claims
they've not decided so can i just ask
you then why is your government so bad
at actually uh sending back failed
asylum seekers in 2010 we sent back 10
663
last year we sent back 806 failed asylum
seekers why i i i i don't think the the
the fault of the officials i think they
do their their level best i didn't
guitar that they're so bad i think it's
that our brilliant legal uh profession
is so good
at uh finding reasons why they should
not be returned
that's your answer it's not to do with
the fact you haven't been able to um
enter into agreements with other
countries you haven't got a replacement
for the dublin agreement
i i
might okay my impression is that and
certainly if you look at what happened
with the dublin agreement that break
down across the broad and uh the the
return returns agreements uh uh have
been extremely hard to well let's just
put it this way that you sent back 20
people who came across in small boats
across the channel last year 20 and
there were 28 000 that came can i just
ask you do you expect the cuts to civil
servants that you're talking about the
20 30 or 40 cuts will that help the home
office get to grips with some of these
problems or make it worse i i think that
certainly what you need to say when you
talk about the uh asylum seekers
crossing the channel illegally
and in uh very frail vessels no your
quotes
the way to fix that is not just by uh by
having more civil servants i think it is
uh to have a proper deterrent for the
people
having more privileges and
to reduce uh the numbers of people who
are being made to risk their lives okay
just my final question if i may
could you just confirm and i just
appreciate a yes or a no
that you met with the former kgb officer
alexandra lebanov lebedev
when you were foreign secretary without
officials on the 28th of april 2018.
well
i i i have to i i'd have to check but uh
you're having a lapse of memory again no
but that sounds but you know if you're
asking a very specific question about a
very specific date and i really i i
would have to i'd have to get back i
certainly have met the gentleman in
question who's uh who's uh
who used to be the proprietor of the
london evening standard i was
uh when i was mayor of london so i i i
certainly am not going to deny having
met
uh alexander lebedev i certainly have as
far as i remember
he used to own uh the london evening but
with officials when you were foreign
secretary did you meet with officials or
without officials
look i i
i've certainly met him without officials
right and uh you know as i said he's a
he's a perhaps you could write a
proprietor of a
nation who could write to us with this
very happy very happy to a very happy
specific answer to that very specific
question yes
yes
prime minister i mean you said you met
him without officials was that
presumably was when you were mayor of
london when you were foreign secretary
did you meet alexander liberdev i i i
think i would definitely do but but i
probably did
as i said i would i would need to check
you used to regularly meeting him i mean
is it probably because you meet him
often or probably because you can't
remember i i've met him on a very few
occasions
on the occasion you're mentioning if
that was when i was foreign secretary
then yes
without officials yes
that means did you report your officials
that you had met in
uh i think i i think i did mention it
yes and where did you meet him
um
i i met him
uh initially as it happens but i i
really you know
i forget anyway but perhaps you'll feel
righteous personal engagement wasn't it
yeah
it was if that's exactly right
um
we'll move on caroline notes equalities
committee prime minister uh you've
referred to the homes for ukraine in the
ukrainian family schemes can you give us
any indication of what proportion of the
visas issued have been to women
uh i can't caroline i'm sorry i'll have
to write to you okay so we're not
collecting official statistics on that
but the indicative ones suggest that
it's 82
are women many of whom have children
with them what safeguarding concerns do
you have
about ukrainian women being here in the
uk
so one of the reasons why the
uh
the scheme you know people initially
complained that uh the scheme was was
slow but we wanted to make sure that uh
people when they arrived uh got
um
you know
a safe environment and uh so as far as i
know the
work is done to ensure that
they're they're with families or with
people who will uh who will look after
them properly do you feel comfortable
that the accommodation is checked in
many instances after people have arrived
to the best of my knowledge they they
have everybody that i've met or who's
been involved in the scheme says it's
it's working very well
so you do feel comfortable if
accommodation is checked after people
have arrived i i can't tell you caroline
exactly what checks have done on the
accommodation after uh people have
arrived but i know that
safeguarding is done to to make sure
that they have a good experience while
they're here do we know how many are no
longer with their original sponsors
i can't give you that i don't know
there's certainly indications that there
could be as many as 660 ukrainian
households already who are owed a duty
because under the homelessness uh
prevention
do you have any concerns about where
they're going to end up
uh i i don't i don't know that the uh
that it's right that the
uh that there are that many ukrainians
who are homeless in the in the ukraine
in the uk um
uh i think that uh where they where they
where there are
um
uh arrivals who uh have had a problem
with their their sponsors with the with
the household uh that the councils have
a duty uh to provide a roof for them and
that is supported by uh a grant of ten
thousand five hundred pounds per per
person
so we're not we're not currently aware
of any ukrainian sleeping rough okay the
statistics show that there are 660
ukrainian households owed a prevention
or relief duty for homelessness are you
uh you said earlier today i think to
clive betts that people would be able to
switch between the ukrainian family
scheme and the homes for ukraine scheme
when do you think that'll be possible uh
so we're trying to
uh to speed things up
um i i i can't tell you when we're we're
going to be able to uh make the make
those two schemes um
uh
allow people to move uh fluidly from one
uh to the next but uh clearly there's a
logic in
in there and if people should be able to
switch between the family scheme and the
homes for ukraine scheme should they
also be able to switch sponsor within
the homes for ukraine scheme and have
the 350 pounds month funding follow them
interesting idea
um
i'll we'll have a look at it i can't i
i'm not going to
extemporize a a solution if a lone woman
has fled a sponsor's home because of
safeguarding concerns do you think the
funding should follow her well i can see
the logic of that yes but
you know
you know the i will certainly have a
have a look at
what's happening i'm sure i'm sure that
particular issue is something that uh
homework is starting for perhaps
minister harrington and minister gove if
they're still with us could look at that
can i ask you specifically when it comes
to safeguarding concerns yes
should safeguarding always be
straightforward
um
well
of course thank you for that and finally
uh
we know that people traffickers are
operating between uh on the borders of
ukraine particularly targeting women and
young girls
do you have any concerns that ukrainian
women are going to turn up on the
beaches of dover trafficked here in
small boats and if that happens
what should we do to help them well
to the best of my knowledge that that is
not happening at the moment we have safe
and legal routes
several safe and eagle routes for
ukrainians right now earlier this week a
group of female ukrainian mps were at
the osce meeting specifically expressing
concerns about people trafficking what
are you doing with other european
governments to make sure that that does
not happen
the home office starts a huge amount to
tackle
people trafficking upstream working with
other
european governments the national crime
agency is heavily involved in that are
they specifically looking at the threat
to ukrainian women
i i know that uh one of the one of the
things that when when
the exodus began
one of the things that we were
particularly doing is making sure that
we had uh staff at the uh
particularly in poland uh who were
looking after the interests of people
who are leaving and uh who might be
wanting to come to this country are
those staff trained to deal with people
trafficking
i i believe so but i would i would have
to get back to you on that thank you
bernard um thank you um
stephen kram thank you welcome
good afternoon prime minister we're
going to move on to cost of living
issues now can i start very briefly by
asking you with the appointment of a new
chancellor last night is the
government's position still that it's
committed to a full uprating as full
social security operating next april
based on september's cpi figure so
that's full up rating of benefits and
pensions next april
uh i i'm aware of no change in uh in our
in our policy has the new chancellor
indicated any desire or intention to
look or reopen
any of the decisions we've made in
response to the cost of living crisis or
indeed are there any areas that you
would want him to reopen
uh i i think that what the new
chancellor is going to uh going to want
to do is continue with the
the package of support that we've that
we set out and don't forget that there's
1200 pounds
for the 8 million most vulnerable
households
going into people's bank accounts this
month
400 pounds to help everybody with the
costs of of energy uh cuts to uh to
council tax uh i know that the uh the
new chancellor is certainly uh committed
to uh to all of that
so as far as your concerned prime
minister the basic template for our
response to the cost of living crisis
indeed our wider tax and spend strategy
remains locked for now under the new
chancellor well i know that you're that
they're your they'll you're you're
pushing a bit too high uh i think that
um that would be you know that's not
quite the conclusion that that i want
you to draw i certainly think that at
the new chancellor will want to think
about what we can do
uh to do even more uh to help people
um
whether on the on the fiscal frontal or
whatever the the minister for brexit
opportunities recently
uh appeared to be quite dismissive of
obr forecasts and i think even appear to
question the usefulness of the opr
altogether do you prime minister have
confidence in ovr forecasts i i think
that the obr forecasts are very useful
uh i don't think that they should
necessarily but my experience is they
don't always turn out to be
to be to be correct but that doesn't
mean that they're
without value when if they turned out to
be correct
well it's it's about it
it's about an answer i think a
rhetorical question so when the obr back
in when the obr in march prime minister
um
predicted that the uk is going to see
the fastest drop in living standards
since the 1950s is that an obr forecast
that you accept i think that we've got
to be realistic that there is going to
be a lot of uh economic
pain and we've got to we've got to be
frank with people about that and that is
certainly the the case um and
um
what we will do so what what we're doing
is is trying to uh help the
uh
the lowest income households as much as
possible and and actually uh they they
may get
fully compensated uh but there will
certainly be or
virtually fully but there will certainly
be a lot of pressure for for a while
that pressure will then abate we will
get inflation under control that is the
big problem right now but i'm i'm very
confident that it will have abated by uh
by next year and is the latest economic
advice that you're receiving prime
minister that that obr forecast about
drop in living standards is indeed
correct or are you receiving advice
any evidence to point to a softer
landing or indeed things getting even
worse next week i i want to i want to
repeat things that
an inflation spike like this
takes a long time to work through
and
we've just got to be realistic about
that
and uh there is going to be there is
going to be pressure on people's incomes
and there's going to be pressure on on
on
on on people's budgets and
it really really is
we cannot ignore that we will try to
help people uh with been a massive um or
very substantial contributions to their
to their
their paper to their uh
to support them the and i mentioned some
of the the sums that make up the 37
billion pounds of support
but we also have to
fix the underlying causes of inflation
i mean prime minister you said a few
moments ago
i think you're absolutely correct it's
going to be very very painful and indeed
if the obr forecast about living
standards is anything like correct it's
going to be absolutely brutal for many
families out there in the country
in in the months i i didn't say that
stephen
that's my language yeah your language
was painful very painful
um
do you accept friends and forgive me for
asking this that
at a time of such economic crisis for
the country for many families up and
down the country that what the country
needs is a government with the very best
team
the very best of focus absolutely
squarely focus on tackling these issues
and when you see prime minister people
like
um
john glenn leaving government people
like kemi badanok people like
neil o'brien one of the intellectual
architects of leveling up
do not feel prime minister the very
ability capacity of this government
to address these enormous overhanging
issues
is is deteriorating as we speak well
when i when i came into
uh into into parliament i think there
were about
140 conservative mps i don't remember
exactly what the number uh was uh there
are now
uh 365 or so
the 360 uh there or there abouts there
is a wealth of talent stephen
and
we should we should be we should be
confident in our ability to and as for
your point about um the the government
focusing the government is certainly
focusing on the issues that matter and
today we're cutting taxes for everybody
uh by 330 pounds uh for
30 million people uh just this day i've
talked about the 1200 pounds uh but
we've just got half a million people off
well very cool
thank goodness
very quickly
you're being very kind about um as on
the back benches but actually i think
you're going to find it extremely hard
to appoint people of the same caliber of
the kind of ministers i've mentioned to
you i think you find it extremely
difficult
you know you don't need to reply to that
point i think the point is being made uh
you're catching my iu a little bit under
time yes yeah thank you
i mean
just following on from that you've had
more resignations since any prime
minister's in 1932
michael gove has told you to go they
shall adds up the game's up really will
you be prime minister tomorrow
of course uh mr mcneil uh but next week
but i'm here to i'm rather than giving
any running commentary on uh my own
i'm just standing all afternoon i'll
talk about what the government is doing
and okay and that is
so that's what i was telling stephen
and uh
more and more
hugh merriman transport
uh thank you sir in the six minutes i
have uh prime minister i want to talk to
you about transport policy delivery if
you if you're focused um
i want to talk about rail air and also
road starting with rail
do you have all of the policy and legal
um interventions and levers that you
need to end this rail strike
uh thanks very much
uh hugh
um
i think the
i i call it on the
uh the uh
union barons and the and the railway
companies to sort this out i think that
they should be able to to do it
and i think that uh yes we probably do
need a few more uh
specifically what what i think i think
that you could you could have minimum
service levels you could have ballot
thresholds and as you know we're
bringing in uh i i think we've already
uh brought in uh the provision for uh
agency uh workers where that's necessary
that's not gonna fix uh problems like uh
like train drivers you know get agency
workers to to drive a train
uh but
uh the the argument i would make is that
you need to
um
you need to modernize so so let me just
again focus on the levers because i
think under the conservative manifesto
there was a line that said only the
conservatives could get brexit done a
few more things
and stop passengers being held hostage
by the unions but in fact
and that was with the introduction of
that policy of minimum service levels
yet that hasn't been introduced
and people are being held hostage which
might be your your view so why did you
not bring
with an 80-seat majority that
legislation through before this fight
that is a very good question
and the answer is and the answer is we
should have done it and the trouble was
we had a lot of codeword stuff to deal
with and i'm afraid it got pushed to the
right and it and and i thought you might
say that there have been other things we
know to do notwithstanding covenant okay
let me move on to airports so massive
disruption in the airports people having
their holidays cancelled the last minute
why wasn't more done to stop
airline was putting more flights in
place than that we knew their staff
could that they had the bandwidth of
staff to deal with
uh
well the the the airlines should not be
uh
abusing uh passengers in the way that uh
uh that they have been and i i think
that there should be uh there should be
greater protection but i think the
um but again this is all there should be
my question is why has why hasn't there
been the the i i i because basically we
were trying to get any airlines flying
at all i mean uh diana has asked a very
good question about uh
about passports uh where we're putting
huge numbers of people trying to speed
up the delivery of passports uh we had a
situation which uh no air no airlines
were moving uh at all we had to put
eight billion as you remember uh hugh
into into supporting the airline
industry
indeed
but
gatwick for example has controlled the
number of flights that will be able to
fly out during july and august because
they can see the airlines are trying to
fly at 2018 levels so they could see the
number of staff coming on so they've
taken action other airports haven't
necessarily the regulator the civil
aviation authority doesn't have the
power up front to implement these types
of policies shouldn't it have that power
uh
i'm
willing to be persuaded that it uh that
it but it should because when we put a
report on that basis the recommendation
was rejected by government on the basis
that um there wouldn't be a proposal to
give the regulator upfront powers to
take action including to help with
compensation
well uh
perhaps we can push
what more powers we might need to take
to get the airlines to uh to pave
responsibly towards their passengers but
i think the experience of the public has
been pretty wretched uh at the moment
and uh for all sorts of reasons and uh
they need to do much much better okay
and turning to another area of policy
which perhaps needs to change
at the moment four percent of the
exchequers revenues come from motoring
taxes those will plummet to zero when we
all drive electric vehicles are you
serious about getting a new form of
road pricing policy in place
to fill that hole if not how will it be
filled i look i think uh road
road pricing
um is
something that uh you know we will
eventually have to
uh to consider uh the i'm not attracted
to it i seem to remember
uh i'm
but i think i'm i successfully
campaigned to remove the western
extension of the uh of the congestion
i'm not talking about the road from
charging in that way i'm talking about
as we do at the moment we charge people
for the mile they drive because that's
what fuel duty does so you'll have to
replace that i see what you mean so you
so like for electric vehicles as well so
they said that you charge a mileage yeah
something along those lines
yeah well
it is certainly the case that we will
need a substitute for for fuel duty and
this surveillance comes back to my point
about policy delivery because this is
imminent we're we're introducing
electricity can i can i say this if you
don't mind um so for three months prime
minister number 10 has had a
recommendation just to look at this
because something has to fill the four
percent of a working body to look at it
the treasury signed off on it and for
three months it's been sat in number 10.
one week i'm told somebody's signed off
and next week someone else has looked at
it and actually has stopped it and it's
stuck and my question is the inertia
inside number 10 perhaps because of the
events that we'll go on to talking about
is that
actually we say it's nonsense but
actually it's a nonsense that we've been
waiting three months just for someone to
sign off on something which fills four
percent of the exchequer that is the
nonsense do not agree something should
be done or if you can't do it do you
think that perhaps someone else could
come in and run it properly yeah well
so this is so so this
this number 10 actually
was the first government in europe uh to
set a timetable for uh moving away from
uh from
uh
hydrocarbon from internal combustion
engine uh
cars by 2030. yeah i know exactly that's
why that's why
you should follow through on the
consequences
we've got blistering speed uh we will
certainly look at the we're looking at
all uh fiscal proposals to uh to replace
uh fuel duty and i'm happy to have you
you're not you're actually currently
sitting on all proposals i cannot
believe that the the the uh treasury is
showing the slightest hesitational
reluctance to find a new way of no
that's my point the treasury signed off
on it number ten then insisted on
looking at it and it's been sat on it
for three months i think andrew griffith
is currently the one that's now said no
i don't like this uh and we are
therefore stuck having thought we
cleared all the words
i will take it up with uh prime minister
i've just added thank you
i have a shadow transport secretary in
2000 and road charging was seen as the
future then
successive governments have dodged it
but why is your government dodging it
when you're already abandoning the the
the revenue stream but does hydrocarbons
so so who you know why why do you think
we necessarily are we've got to find a
way of
you've got to find a way of
filling the uh filling the gap left by
right you've actually got a target for
it for eliminating um fossil fuel cars
but you haven't got any plan in place to
replace the revenue well i i
i think
i think it's highly unlikely
that the uh the treasury will let any
opportunity go to find uh to raise
revenue from uh from motoring i think to
substitute
what we want to do is we want for the
purposes of the environment to encourage
uh the take-up of low-carbon vehicles
and that's why the the fiscal uh the
fiscal uh strategy is framed as as it
currently is
that's what we're doing for the time
being my apologies to darren jones base
i should walk you in earlier
thank you
prime minister
how's how's your week going
terrific
like like many others uh it's it's uh no
uses a lot did michael cave come and
tell you to resign today i i i think i
said earlier uh sir that i'm not gonna
i'm here to talk about uh what the
government is doing i'm not gonna give a
running commentary on uh on political
events okay um so let's talk about what
the government's doing you've just said
today that the government's giving the
biggest tax cut in a decade but it's a
tax cut to your own tax rise isn't it
uh no one uh what it does is it gives
people
uh 30 million people
a by lifting the thresholds it gives
them on average a tax cut of
330 pounds against the tax rise that you
previously announced in fact freezing
tax allowances for average income
taxpayers means they're going to pay
46.8 billion pounds more over the next
four years tax is going up not down
isn't it
it is certainly true that we what we've
had to do
is uh
is make sure that we deal with
the fiscal impacts of kovid and
i think the committee will remember uh
that this was a uh we had a colossal
fall in output uh
we had the biggest pandemic for a
hundred years uh and uh we had to we had
to look after people's businesses to the
tune of 408 billion times that money
doesn't grow on trees
so in order to protect our schools our
hospitals uh we of course have had to
increase that we've had the uh the the
the health and and care levy i just
think exactly what we're doing prime
minister i just need to help you on the
prime minister on average
i asked about the tax cut announced
today but i'll just move on let's let's
look about the economy before the
pandemic because you mentioned the
pandemic understandable uh
event that was very difficult for
government but before the pandemic uh
between 2010 when the conservative party
came into office and before the pandemic
national debt increased by 640
billion pounds it's now 100 of national
wealth and you keep announcing tax cuts
and spending plans at the same time are
you just going to keep putting more and
more debt onto the nation's credit card
so you were just complaining about taxes
going up i'm asking you about what
you're doing to government time to get
your story straight my facts are from
the truth
what we're doing
is uh we have to be sensible we have to
be uh responsible uh we're we're making
sure that we
uh
manage the public finances uh in a in a
prudent way uh but i think that there uh
there will uh be be scoped for
uh for for foreign starts in due time
maybe imminently perhaps can i just move
on can i do it can i move on to economic
growth you said yesterday you welcomed
your new chancellor and nadeem sahari
yes uh because he would grow the economy
in a way that presumably rishi sunat
couldn't and but we're more likely to
end up in the recession i don't think i
said that but anyway well more likely to
end up in a recession this winter aren't
we
look i think as i was saying to to
stephen i think that
the economy is that people are going to
be under under a lot of pressure but i
think we'll get through it do you think
there'll be a recession in the world i
think i think that
there'll be a lot of pressure caused by
the price spike uh we are going to do
everything we can to shield people to
deal with the underlying causes of
inflation uh whether that's through the
energy markets uh or the labor markets
or uh or uh whatever and there's a lot
we can do and i think we'll emerge
stronger the other side okay um so
you've often said and your supporters
have often said that you've got all the
big calls right as prime minister
but actually on tax on debt on growth on
pay things have been getting worse not
better 14 million people i understand
voted for you in 2019 you've let them
down haven't you no i think that what
what they uh can see is the government
that gets on relentlessly with a program
of uniting and and leveling up we've got
the biggest uh investment in
infrastructure for for a century 650
billion pounds uh going in on roads all
the all the things that uh hugh was
talking about roads rail uh transport uh
of all kinds housing uh it is a
colossally ambitious program that we
could that we are we are still uh doing
and at the same time because actually we
got the as you put it down the big calls
right on i didn't agree with it well
we came out of lockdown faster we got
the we got it right uh with with the
vaccine uh that enabled us that's put
our second position okay and to look
after people thank you
we're just going to move on to my next
question i'd like to just read something
out to you uh quote when a regime has
been in power for too long when it has
fatally exhausted the patience of the
people and when oblivion finally beckons
i am afraid that across the world you
can rely on the leaders of that regime
to act solely in the interests of
self-preservation and not in the
interests of the electorate who authored
that quote
you're trying me was it was it uh was it
was it cicero
uh what was it was it was it aristotle
parallel was it prime minister you
wouldn't like this
thing but i think you might be more like
plato
maybe
maybe
now can i just finish because i'm about
to run out of time prime minister okay
because i made a joke there but in all
sincerity and i know this must be
difficult for you personally but
this isn't funny
it's not a game people are struggling
across the country i'm just finished
it's not brave for you to carry on doing
this i think in my view you're hurting
the country prime minister
just on a very human level surely you
must know that
it's in the country's interest for you
to leave now isn't it i i look i i think
that the country is going through tough
times and i think that we have the
uh the biggest
you know you're making a a point about
about duty right yeah and
uh i i look at the uh the issues that
this country faces i look at the um
the pressures that people are are under
and the need for government to focus on
that on on their priorities which is
what we are doing i look at
the biggest war in europe for 80 years
and
i cannot for the life of me
see or how it is responsible just to to
walk away from that as i said earlier on
in
pmq's particularly not when you have a
mandate of the kind that
we won
two three years ago but shouldn't
shouldn't
as prime minister you actually spell out
that the
pressure the economy is under is
actually very very serious because not
just of the invasion but because we have
decided to make the necessary sacrifices
in order to resist beauty
and we are an economic war with russia
now with putin he's coining it on the
energy sales we are our economies are
suffering as a direct consequence of the
sanctions shouldn't we be spelling out
that it's going to be tough that these
sacrifices are necessary to make in
order to secure the security of our
constituents you know thank you
supporters and that that is exactly the
point that uh i i had been making i
think i made it yesterday in the monday
i should say in the statement in uh on
uh the summits
and it's the point it's the point that
resonates with colleagues around the
table in in nato and g7 and other places
because
um
the the cost of of not standing up to
putin
is that you legitimate or you uh you
encourage further acts of aggression uh
in other parts of the former soviet
union destabilizing uh the whole
continent if not the the world causing
further economic distress and
uncertainty going on for years
and years and that's why
i made the point about
the
decades of peace and stability that
followed the second world war
when we finally learned to stand up to
dictators not to accept that borders
could be changed by force that that
decision
led to decades
of uh of the rule of international law
uh uh global trade expansion of global
trade peace and stability and and we
need to we need to re to inaugurate uh
that era again thank you prime minister
rob half on education
starting off with fuel and then i'm
going to say
sure segway's in um if i could just move
from uh ukraine to a fish and chip shop
in harlow prime minister if i may
um they are down 150
customers a month their takings are down
5 000 pounds a month their energy bills
have gone up from eighteen hundred
pounds to three thousand pounds a month
and now he's got to pay over two pounds
to fill up his
car
and the vehicles um two pounds a liter
can you understand what is fueling the
paulia protests
whilst i don't agree with direct action
i do have sympathy for what they're
asking for
and is it not the case that the 5p fuel
duty cut whilst welcome was swallowed up
and that actually
this is unsustainable
and that you need to slash either fuel
duty or vat
but also to
look at introduce a pump watch monitor
because just finally we know that since
the 14th of june the wholesale price for
diesel fell by 7.2 per liter but filling
up costs increased by 8.1 p for petrol
the wholesale price dropped by 14.
p but the pump price rocketed by
17.4 p so motorists everywhere you look
at it they're being fleeced by the
government and they're increased by the
oil companies so what are you going to
do it because if you don't do something
there is going to be a canada style uh
haulier protest around the palace of
westminster no doubt that this is going
to spread yeah well robert thank you you
know you you've been campaigning on this
for years
and years and
i listen to you very uh attentively um
you know as you as you say we have cut
fuel duty by uh by 5p uh for
a liter that's
it's only about 100 quid a year i
appreciate that that's not much for uh
for people that's being swallowed up by
uh what's happening on the four courts
so we are doing a if you grant is
i believe doing a pump watch scheme uh
to ensure that cuts that we are putting
in uh do get uh do get passed on but uh
clearly
uh
the pressure is that and i i hear you i
hear you loud and clear one of the i
think uh before angus leaves one of the
benefits of brexit is you can cut uh vat
on fuel uh just just as
say as i should have i should i should i
should have pointed that out but you did
you recognize they need you need to
slash it um you need to literally cut it
by a significant amount because this is
unsustainable it's hurting our frontline
services seeing our bus services hitting
transportation and it's hurting our
businesses as well i i hear you live and
clear tonight you know
so we have a new chance though we will
see where we get to all that but i hear
you
okay if i can move to um education i've
been
i was distressed about the uh closure of
schools and i thought it was a huge
mistake that they were closed for most
pupils did you encode during covert i
thought it was a huge mistake something
acknowledged by the previous education
secretary now chancellor
we now know that there are 124 000
uh so-called ghost children and who have
not yet returned to school persistent
absence
has gone up from 1.6 million to 1.7
million
what is um the government doing to get
these kids back into
uh back into school
and and will you look at rolling out a
program of
2000 school attendance mentors not
necessarily new employees but school
employees local existing local
authorities employers and charity
employees to work with the families to
get these children back into school and
you could use um existing money from the
supporting families fund the 80 million
pounds from the supported families fund
in order to do so
so
first of all i i agree with your your
overall uh premise that you know it was
awful that schools had to to close uh we
didn't want to do it we tried to keep it
for as short a period as possible
um
we're trying to get uh kids back into
school as as much as we uh as we can uh
one other thing we're spending about
five million pounds on school on on
catch-up uh but one of the things that
i think is important and
i believe it very strongly is trying to
trying to to give kids one-on-one or
one-on-two uh one-on-three uh the
opportunity of tuition which they might
not otherwise have but those are the
children in school so we need to get
until not the ones who are not in school
um 1.7 million persistent absence 100
000 children disappeared off the 124 000
children who disappeared off the school
rolls the so-called ghost children
yeah uh
robert we'll we're we will do
everything we can to get these uh
these children back into what you're
doing back into school and what what
we're doing
is uh putting another five billion
pounds of putting 500 pounds into
education uh recovery so there's there's
a lot for
for tutoring uh but also
direct targeting for those uh for those
most in uh in need uh so that
uh a two billion uh pound fund uh which
should help uh uh uh schools to to
to get uh those those ghost children uh
back but um this is something that you
have that i'm afraid is gonna require a
joined up effort it requires councils it
requires
a lot of bodies to to come together to
get those uh their children back into
children's commissioner said that these
uh she wants all the kids back by
uh september i just think the engine the
priority for education should be to
uh the education department should be to
get these children back into school it's
just wrong that uh so many children are
missing school and not yet returned they
have faced safeguarding pressures
damaged their mental health lifetime
trying to joining county line gangs and
i would urge you to look at the
supporting families fund as i mentioned
the 80 million power just very finally i
bought through a bill in a 10-minute
rule bill in i'll call the national
school infrastructure bill which would
treat schools the same as other national
infrastructures to stop schools closing
again and that if god forbid there was
another wave of coded and the government
decided to make a decision to to close
schools their children's commissioner
would have a veto and that parliament
would make an individual decision on
school closures every six
weeks what's the question would you do
you support that concept of making
schools partnerships i'll be very happy
to uh to look at it and uh you know i i
understand uh where you're coming from i
think that it's clear from the data i'm
seeing that the damage to uh kids
education particularly for the uh
done by the lockdown uh you know
continues and it's disappointing to see
the literacy and numeracy uh stats we
need to uh we need to do better and and
there's no question in my mind that's
been partly caused by uh by the closures
thank you right we're going to move on
to integrity and politics um we are
bound to overrun somewhat because we
have to do this subject justice so i
hope prime minister you'll be able to
stay until we've finished rob halphon
justice sorry rob neil of neil justice
how important is the truth to you prime
minister a very important bob
and accuracy of language and statement
also
very important very very important and
you expect those standards
from those who work for you in downing
street either as spokespeople or those
who brief ministers to speak on behalf
of the government yes
can you help me about
this
the story concerning the honourable
member for tamworth wrote
on the morning late evening of the of
the 29th morning of the thursday the
30th
in the course of subsequent days a
number of statements were made uh by a
spokesman on your behalf
in which it was said uh in terms that
you had not been aware of any specific
allegations
that's correct yes uh and and that was
not right and
uh the
just so the committee understands uh the
um
what i was doing so on the the friday
the
uh when the allegations were
put to me in in detail and the fact that
the complaint
had been made i was mainly engaged in uh
talking to a witness and and removing
the whip from uh the uh the membrane in
question that's what i get i suppose i
can come to that problem what we should
have done at the same time i then i then
uh i then left the uh the building but
what we should have done is gone over uh
all the uh interactions between uh
government me and uh the member of
tamworth and got a four uh timeline and
uh and i'm afraid we didn't and that's
and i should have done that uh but as a
result uh some things were said that uh
that weren't right uh when where as soon
as
i was aware of the discrepancy we uh we
okay well what we do know is that on the
5th of july um lord macdonald salford
who was the permanent
permanent secretary of the secretary at
the foreign office said this that the
line that had been put out was not
accurate should now accept
said this in a letter uh to the
parliamentary commissioner standards mr
johnson was briefed in person about the
initiation and outcome of the
investigation there was a formal
complaint
uh indeed i'm sure you've seen john's
letter now
do you accept the content uh yes
and so
that's that's entirely right uh correct
so if i could just you accept what laura
donald says and i
wouldn't want to say that acceptable
absolutely everything he says because
but what i can certainly tell you is
that
i don't have it before me and what i can
certainly tell you is that
um
there was a complaint
and you told the member for tamworth
um
[Music]
in uh 2019 yes
and that
that complaint was upheld yes the matter
was resolved within the foreign office
uh it's uh uh
was not deemed to
approach the uh
anything like the level of criminality
or or the ministerial code but i was i
was briefed on it in a uh on two
occasions right by the propriety and
ethics
people
uh who tell us that it was happening and
then um
and on both occasions what i had was an
extremely uh
on friday there was no record of that in
number 10.
in your mind there's no written record
of that forget forgive me um it isn't
common for a serving minister of the
crown to be subject to an allegation of
sexual impropriety is it
uh i
i don't want to go into the details of
the uh of the allegations because i
think there are human uh resources
i'm not i'm not certain that's a fair
characterization
at all events it was a serious matter
and this was someone who had worked
closely on your leadership team only a
few months before so you'd be aware it
was sensitive
uh that's that's that's sort of yes it
was also it was also
um
to be fair
well as i say
now that uh
when it when i when it was drawn to my
attention uh a couple of days later that
there was a discrepancy between what we
were saying
uh abroad as it were what another ten
was saying
and the fact that this
uh briefing had taken place i took steps
to clear it up as soon as the suggestion
you couldn't recall that was said on
your behalf is that a serious
explanation i couldn't recall this
unusual incident of someone who was a
close political ally
what
what we failed to do on the on the first
day
was to go over all the uh the possible
interactions between me and
uh and
uh the
member in question
uh all the possible uh decisions that i
might have taken as it happened the
uh the issue
um the
the report about the uh the complaint
was not raised to me as a as a point for
for any kind of decision
uh it was simply something that was
mentioned to be in the in the margin uh
of other meetings as a point of as as i
as i as i recall as a point of
information about what had happened
because it was the it was the foreign
office that dealt with it the prime
minister when you were considering
appointing him
into the government most recently
um how true is it that actually you
wanted him to be chief win
not to
my recollection uh so about it i don't i
don't think so i think i think the
suggestion was that he was going to be
deputy chief win
that's what happened and what happened
to all the messages pouring into downing
street about the risk of appointing this
person well
there's plenty of them
well i don't know about i don't know how
many there were but there were certainly
i couldn't i mean there's a cultural
problem here why couldn't the system
hear that there was concern about this
appointment i i don't think that's
entirely fair well then why did you
refer it if you're talking about
the ethics and proprietary um directory
in the cabinet office why why why was
that necessary if that wasn't a
conversation okay
every every ministerial appointment
automatically goes to
to the proprietary ethics team so they
look at they look at everyone
um william bragg
good afternoon prime minister
um i appreciate that today is a day of
events and though this meeting has not
quite resembled a moscow show trial
because i think certainly they were
livelier um it must be nonetheless quite
difficult and i do pay tribute to you
for turning up
today i wouldn't dream of being anywhere
else
having said that are you delighted to be
having said that at which point does it
become impossible for the queen's
government to be continued i i i really
think that uh you know that
you're
william you're underestimating the
the talent energy
and sheer ambition
of uh of of members of parliament and
they want to get things done they want
to get things done uh for their
constituents and uh the government of
the country is being carried on uh with
ever increasing uh energy well they seem
to want to get one thing done at the
moment in time i agree with you on that
but i think the issue that we have is
that we've had at least my initial
calculation at the start of the meeting
was 27 minutes and a's resigning there
had been more in the meantime
do you think there are swelling ranks of
those young thrusters on the back
benches who could replace them
i i think it highly likely yes
ambition could that not be considered
delusional
yeah that that's a sort of uh a moral
judgment about human nature that you
know i wouldn't venture to to comment on
i think that uh
we maybe were all deluded in our our
ambitions but i think most people who
come to this place actually in spite of
what everybody says about mps are
actuated by the highest motives and most
people want to serve their constituents
and get stuff done
and that is that is the reality entirely
so
so in terms of that assessment of
individuals which qualities in the form
of deputy chief whip appeal to you most
you know uh i i i think it was
uh
so let me just you know big picture no
as i've as i've said before i think
let me let me be clear that i uh with
the benefit of hindsight i can see that
that appointment as i said in the uh in
the house and
i think i said on tv as well i think
that appointment was a was a mistake
but it was the policies of ministers
our government appointments based upon
ability
so it was it was put to me that uh uh
that like uh everyone we appoint uh the
the member had excellent administrative
skills administrative schools was he
behind what's colloquially known as
operation save big dog
he look to the best of my memory he was
uh he was in addition to serving uh
as deputy chief whip under the previous
prime minister he was
uh he
did
a stint at the foreign office and then a
stint at the department of uh community
local government when
he was involved he
had a role in housing and
the accounts i had
were positive
casting our minds back to january and
february it was a tricky time
and certainly some people in the shadow
whipping operation
uh use their charm
in order to persuade i think it's fair
to say others
used aspects of what we might describe
as being
offensive to work that wonder for you
so why was
mr pincher
the first to be invited into downing
street on the day of the reshuffle when
the
most senior job available was at a chief
win
ordinarily it would be awarded to the
first person
okay that's who you you you're getting
back to berlin's point i think that's a
that's a red herring
did any colleagues come to you on that
day and express concerns about that
appointment or potentially not not to me
but concerns what what happened was that
concerns were expressed actually after
uh i had made uh the appointment i was
in there for four hours though before
the appointment was made
for that reason i made the appointment
and then when it got on with making
other appointments uh but there was a
problem that needed to be uh to be
resolved
i think that
i
ought to given that this
uh this member is um
they're investigating him prime minister
they're not investigating you yeah but i
i i don't want to offer any more
commentary that might not be i'm sorry
about asking michael might not be
correct about it well come on it's quite
a different straightforward question
about your judgment and how you approach
appointing ministers yes so
let me let me be clear the the
uh the
i made the appointment
uh there was then uh i then got on with
making other appointments uh there was
any delay while the matter was was
cleared up uh in announcing the
appointment
uh i was told that it had been cleared
up and we got with it what needed to be
cleared up uh
it was a matter concerning another
colleague but i really don't want to i
it would not be right for me to go into
it no it wouldn't be right because what
happened that colleague wasn't right at
all was it well i wasn't informed of
that at the time but i i having
been subsequently informed about it i
can see that you know it's another
reason not to
have done you know not to have had
that minister if it was true
not to have had that minister uh in post
but on the other hand if it was true do
you believe that colleague who came to
you or made over chosen number 10 or do
you believe mr pinscher
um look i think that these things have
to be
examined i'm not i'm not going to make a
comment about that but what i think what
happened was that my
my team
uh
interviewed both people
and and resolved the matter and that's
why we proceeded as we did
are you familiar with the lasso's
principles
i knew i knew you were going to ask this
and i i i i i can't move on i can i i i
know this is this is about
tommy
dude
yes yeah um
go on remind me so
if you were to go to her majesty
and request as it is a request not to
advise or request a dissolution of
parliament could you give me
two conditions under which her majesty
would be justified in declining
you're asking about you're asking about
something that is not going to happen
unless everybody say crazy is to um
prime minister you said it's not going
to happen unless and less well i think
that i think that the history history
teaches us uh that uh that um
the the best way to have a period of
stability and uh and government and uh
not to have
early elections is to allow people with
mandates to get on and unless what
unless that's what i'm saying so
you said unless what
so unless people ignore that very good
principle that history teaches history
teaches us uh that uh the best way to to
uh avoid uh
uh
pointless political uh
disturbance is to allow the government
that has a mandate to get on and deliver
its mandate and that's right and that's
what that is what we're going to do
unless what i think what you're learning
is sorry mr rag just a minute
the prime minister's unless people
forget that
what does that mean
that means that on the whole i think
that it's a good thing uh if governments
which have a substantial uh mandate uh
from the electorate uh and are doing an
enormous amount of stuff and
when that country is facing uh a lot of
pressure particularly economic uh
pressure uh when the when there are
serious international issues uh at stake
i think on the whole it is sensible and
not to get bogged down in discussion
about electoral politics
but to allow the government of the
country to can i just
remind you that when the prime minister
major
seemed to be threatening a general
election because he was having trouble
with the maastricht bill
it did his no reputation any good at all
well exactly
that there would never have been a
general election can i thank you for
that excellent uh historical uh lesson
and this is exactly the point i'm trying
to make
well i i don't know why you said unless
mr rag
thank you sir
and so
if one of the conditions of the sales
principles is that the sovereign could
rely on finding another prime minister
who could govern for a reasonable period
with a working majority of the house of
commons you'd accept that principle
i think the
uh
all this is i i i want to agree
passionately and strongly with what sir
bernard has said uh if you go back to um
uh prime minister 90s uh that you don't
solve uh
uh problems by uh by threatening to call
elections you've got to get on with what
you're elected to do and that's what the
government is that's what the government
is doing so i'm taking it that you
accept the vassals principles
they sound pretty insofar as in so far
as uh they're designed uh to prevent
uh pointless wild cat elections they
signed this sound sensible to me thank
you sir
mr brown
thank you
welcome prime minister um
have you have you been told of any other
allegations similar to the conduct of mr
pincher about any other ministers in
your time as prime minister
i'm going to have to tell you uh chris
that um
it is all too possible that people have
said things to me about any number of
people
including possibly people around this
horseshoe no have you ever had i i
wouldn't i would be
i i would be it would be a great labor
for me now to sit down and try to
reconstruct every single piece of gossip
or innuendo no no that's not what i'm
asking i'm not asking about gossip and
innuendo i'm asking precisely about that
you you now accept that you were told on
two occasions about mr pincher's the
allegations against mr pinscher that
were um upheld yeah by him
i'm asking have you been told about any
other such um events relating to any
other government minister
for money
um look i'd have to get back to you i
mean i i
i would not want to
um it seems extraordinary i wouldn't
know whether there are allegations
outstanding against your government
ministers of sexual impropriety such
that they they they might um constitute
um potentially criminal offences apart
for anything else
look
nothing that springs to mind okay
uh but you know all right i'm gonna i'm
gonna if there's if there's if you but
what i will say chris is if you have
some information no no
i don't i'm asking you this because it
seems incredible to me that you would
not remember that you've been told this
about somebody who is one of your
closest allies in parliament i think i
try to explain exactly the circumstances
well you happen but let me ask you a
different question and could you not
answer this elsewhere did you say
all the sex pests are supporting me or
words to that effect
people attribute all sorts of uh things
to me
uh
i i don't remember saying those words
but people ascribe all sorts of things
to me that sounds like a yes to me okay
did you say he's a bit handsy
uh i it's not a word i use actually
so that's a definite note i i would not
have used that word but you know it's a
definite no is it look i'm saying i i
people
maybe hear me say all sorts of things i
don't it's not handsy is it as it
happens it's not a word i use but uh all
right did you say picture by name
picture by nature i i'm not going to
get into some uh trivializing discussion
of what i may or may not have said uh
this is a uh
a serious matter that yes the the the
member is now being uh has had a i
believe had a complaint uh made against
him
and that is and that is where i propose
to leave it no but the point is
if you just let me for a moment the
point is that
the allegation is that you have
trivialized
this issue
you've not even remembered it
perhaps because he's he's a useful ally
to you sorry and the point is that then
you appointed somebody who you believed
to be a sex pest
in a position of power and authority
over other people in the parliament so
that's not right because uh the so
under any view
uh the issue at the at the foreign
office
uh was
uh although it was upheld it was
resolved in a way that was satisfactory
it was upheld it was resolving whether
satisfactory to all uh parties and
i i i would i you know there are there
are issues
uh that you know i can't i can't
character i can't be confident that it
was uh a sexual there was there was a
there were sexuals uh
implications
as um
mr mcdonald makes very little mcdonald's
sorry makes it very clear that it was
very similar to the allegations that of
what happened
the problem the trouble is
if i may say so that i was given on
on the occasions when uh i was uh it was
mentioned to me i was given very brief
uh a very sketchy account okay and i and
i really think that
you need it it just seems incredible
that you wouldn't think that that was a
matter worth investigating or talking
about can i ask you but it wasn't
it was investigated and it was and it
was it was investing
was neil parish right to resign from
parliament well i think that uh the
the problem he had was that uh
he was was he right to resign it was his
decision was he right to resign i think
that he he he was
doing something that is not uh normal or
tolerated in in most workplaces so
should chris pincher resign from
parliament well i uh
what i see you you ask about
um
my relationship with i i
took the whip away from him should he
have signed some parliament
that's that's a matter for him
so you think he should stay well
that's a matter for him but i i took
that he no longer sits as a conservative
was it right for sarah dines to ask the
man who was groped in the carlton club
whether he was gay and to say that it
was problematic that he was you're
asking me about uh about you know what
other members are alleged to have said i
can't believe no no there are five other
including people in this room there are
five other mps who witnessed it it's not
in any doubt and i don't think she has
denied it was it right or is it not
victim shaming
let me put it this way i think that
what happened was extremely
serious and as soon as i uh
knew that a complaint had been made and
and i i talked to a uh a witness
and i i removed the whip and you talked
immediately do you not understand why
why this is problematic
because it means that being gay for some
reason or other makes you
sort of asking for it
chris look i i i i see why you're
putting it like that um
i i don't know whether i i'd be very i
very much doubt that sarah meant it to
me you said that way you said yesterday
about chris pincher if i had my time
again this is a bit of captain hindsight
if you don't mind me saying but if i had
my time again you know
who he is yeah yeah it's you
if i had my time again i would think
back on it and recognize he wasn't going
to learn any lessons and he wasn't going
to change
but that's true about you isn't it
you're not going to learn any lessons
and you're not going to change you're
not capable of changing we'll be doing
this again time and time again if you
stay in post won't you well coming to
this committee
i will
uh and yes uh i will you know i hope all
right very much to be
you know what he's invited prime
minister
he's not asking that question but i
don't know quite well i mean you know
exactly what i'm asking you you don't
this is all about you
who he took liberties
and get away with it and allow other
people to get away with taking liberties
so i'm not quite sure what you're what
you're driving out there i think you
know perfectly well what i'm driving at
but you you were asked you were asked
you said on one of the other broadcasts
you said um
um if you're saying you want me to
undergo some sort of psychological
transformation i think that our
listeners would know that that is not
going to happen
isn't that the problem we need a
psychological transformation if you're
to stay in office what what we if with
the greatest possible respect what i
think we all need to do
is focus on the things that our
electorates sent us here to settle for
them and they are uh how to fix the uh
the post code economic shocks and that's
what we're doing uh
how do we make sure that we
improve the life chances of every kid
growing up in this country i think what
robert said about kids being excluded
from school was incredibly important and
i'm going to go away and look at that
these are these are the issues that
matter to the people of this country
that does not exclude the fascination
that uh people will have with these with
these other subjects but that is what i
am focused on no they also need they
also focus on honesty and decency and
propriety and standards in public life
and they hate it when people when they
get caught out just want to turn over
the
the table and and abolish all the rules
but let me ask you one very specific
final question which is just about the
ministerial code because it enshrines
the existence of the independent advisor
on the ministerial interest in the
ministerial code you haven't got one at
the moment i hope you're going to
appoint one very soon and you can tell
us who that's going to be but you
authorized an investigation into mark
spencer's alleged islamophobia which i
gather lord gait had very nearly
completed when will that be completed
and when will it be published oh that's
a very good question i think that um
lord
did give me a brief update on it
i had the impression that it was nearing
a conclusion i'll have to get back to
you and is there going to be a
replacement uh yes there will be uh as
soon as like as soon as we can uh find
one i think the
the difficulty that you haven't got
enough ministers to appoint yet let
alone
you've lost 32 now i'm sure there will
be there will be no shortage of of
candidates
um
if i can just uh
explain
a bit about the the
the replacement for lord guide i do
think there is a there is an issue and i
i think that you you know we need to
think about it collectively which is uh
what happens when we appoint these uh
people i think that they become
uh
they can become a very
pressure to campaigns
and
um you know i'm just giving you my view
they're much more public than they used
to be
so uh christopher i think did an
outstanding job but he was in that he
was he was facing a lot of public
uh pressure he resigned because he
thought you'd lied to him
uh
that's
that's not what he said uh he's he's
he said
uh that he resigned over
over
the question of whether steel tariffs uh
should be
um
uh impeded never steal tariffs you know
perfectly well that's not the truth i
i'm sure you've seen his letter
yes
that's what he says and he and and i
think what he
the issue there was whether
uh
imposing or keeping retaining steel
tariffs in the uk
wto i'm sorry
he resigned as he says in his letter
because he knew that he wanted to
initiate an investigation into your
breaching of the minister but he
couldn't do so without resigning and
that put him an impossible position
that's expressly what his letter says
sorry well then then you must have seen
another letter because that's not what
no i read it and you didn't
um
i have to disagree with you gently there
thank you
thank you
chair after that outbreak of mythomania
let's perhaps get down to some facts so
prime minister you know my job in
parliament is to do the maths you have a
pen there
could you tell us what 148
plus
uh 32
adds up to
uh i i i i'm gonna leave that uh i think
what you're inviting me to do no no i'm
asking you a simple question prime
minister okay and have you earlier asked
i asked you how many mps you have
perhaps can you now someone slip to a
note just to remind you how many
conservative mps
i think do you know how many
conservative mps you have i think this
is a question designed to invite me to
prime minister
you don't want to answer it let me
answer it then so you have a 358 mps you
did think it was 365 you have lost a few
as mr bryant has highlighted you have
now have 32 ministers and pps's who've
resigned it was 28 at the beginning of
this meeting and that and then an
additional
pps who will resign tomorrow
if you don't resign
so that makes it 182 if you include her
so half of 358 prime minister just to
make the math simple for you is 179.
it's not looking very good is it well
you know uh meg you're you're wanting me
to comment on uh lost the confidence
including other members of this room who
may not be in 140 i've been generous
with the double questions sure uh i'm
here to talk about uh the government of
the country the policies mr prime
minister without the support of your
party you cannot govern this country
responsibly or well whatever our
political disagreements i have respect
for the office of prime minister but i'm
afraid i've completely lost respect for
you and your capability to run this i i
think if you look at the the the actions
that we're taking today uh the bills
that were uh we're getting through uh
the we are we are doing some fantastic
things for the people of this country
and we'll continue to
may not be supported downl
the labour party meg but that's not my
problem that's yours
it's it's being reported that there's a
delegation of your cabinet colleagues
waiting in downing street including the
chief whip the transport secretary and
your new chancellor
waiting to tell you when you finish it
today that it's time for you to go how
will you respond to that uh uh
darren
you're you're asking me to comment on
this conversation has been in a few
minutes perhaps
you say uh but i i if you want to ask
about uh what we're doing to help people
uh with the cost of living if you want
to ask about what we're doing to build
more clean green energy supply which uh
this this committee has taken an
interest in that's going to be your
answer to the cabinet colleagues
i'm very happy to to talk to you about
it but i'm not going to give a a running
commentary on political events uh we're
going to get on with the government of
the country um prime minister um
on the question of um the prime
minister's advisor on ministerial
interests
you had two resignations not just one
why did sir alex allen resign well um
sir alex has
i think been pretty well documented i
thank him too
um
uh was asked to investigate allegations
of bullying against the home secretary
uh
the
team produced quite a long uh report
um every which was based on a lot of uh
of extensive work mainly
anonymized interviews
um
and
i read it very thoroughly
and the trouble i found with it was that
uh
nothing that the home secretary
had actually said uh
seemed to me to breach the uh the
threshold uh necessary to trigger her a
resignation although uh the the you
might argue that uh she should have uh
uh spoken in a different way uh from
from time to time it didn't seem to me
uh that that the allegations holy holy
stacked up and i thought that uh it
didn't it didn't it didn't trigger uh a
resignation
it wasn't that wasn't the reason
that yes
the reason he resigned is because he
wouldn't even accept his report
well no well let me let me put it
let me say what happened so sir alex
took a view that
it wasn't that i i did i read the report
from and i read the whole thing uh he he
he didn't actually write it he but he
simply uh read it and drew some through
some conclusions um
i i read all the uh the uh
interrogations that had taken place
and
um
it didn't seem to me that uh although
she might have spoken differently uh
from the time it didn't seem to me that
she deserved to be fired uh of on the
basis of what i read i read i read the
whole thing so
i made this point now the difficulty was
that sir alex thought that
uh
the ministerial code had been breached
even if in a minor way and that any
breach of the ministerial code
uh
necessarily meant a resignation
that view has subsequently been modified
by the committee on standards in public
life
who have said that the ministerial
that there could be gradations of so
what you should have done for breaches
what you should have done is accepted
sir alex allen's report he would not
have resigned
well then it will still be in your gift
not to demand the secretary's
resignation
as i remember the problem was that
um
in order to
i would have had to accept the home
secretary's resignation that was that
was the problem
and and and and that didn't seem to me
although
that didn't seem to be a necessary
outcome i mean supposing
you'll continue in office what are the
lessons you learned from the appointment
of
um chris pincher i look i think the
the the the most important lesson is um
first of all don't uh you know be less
um
uh optimistic about people's ability to
learn and perhaps take a bit more
interest in it
and then secondly
perhaps you should just take a bit more
secondly uh when something like this uh
happens uh make sure that we do a full
uh timetable uh of exactly what happened
and uh or and when it happened uh so
that when people go out to brief uh
they've got all the facts at their
fingertips
it's not a comms failure this prime
minister it's a proprietary and ethics
failure um
um isn't the real lesson that if we
promote people with the wrong
behavior and attitudes in this place it
will give permission for people to
behave in that way which is why we've
got a culture problem in this place
i think that there you're on to i think
it's what you're saying is very
important and i've given this a a a lot
of thought and i do think
there is
a problem
um
[Music]
with alcohol
and
um i i've always resisted this
conclusion in the past um but
it sort of feels to me that
some people simply can't take their
drink
and we need to
we need to think about how we we work
that is
in parliament now this this particular
event
took place
um in
um
[Music]
in the technical parliament
but
there is also there is also
an issue about
uh
standards of behavior and i and i
so i additionally accept
that i should have been uh more
stringent
in my approach and
as i've said earlier i i regret that but
don't we also need to learn i take it
that chris printscher is a friend of
yours and that would be perfectly
respectable that we've let him down
because we didn't give him the help he
needed i think that's a very fair point
what system is there in this place to
support people in that position
what what what do you have in place as a
political as a leader of a political
party to help people who have behavioral
drink problems
well i i think that
we all have a duty as as colleagues to
uh to look after each other and to and
to try to help people and and
uh
that's actually one of the functions of
the whips office department well i mean
unfortunately
whips have other duties
and they rather conflict with our duty
of care
um
and there needs to be something else to
support people who need help who don't
feel that they're giving ammunition to
the people who control their careers
so that doesn't work does it
yet
now we've now got another whip appointed
to take to do the duty of care work i
mean that's not going to work is it
i i i i bernard what are you proposing
well i'm not going to make policy on the
hoof here but
what you've got in place as leader of
your party is not working
would you accept that no i i think there
are there are issues about standards of
behavior and i think there are i i
reluctantly come to the conclusion that
uh there is an issue with alcohol well i
mean you're the last person in the room
to accept that there's a problem
why do you think
integrity in public life has become such
an issue under your premiership well i i
think actually
the
the reality is that
you know i think that people are very
very keen to try to get me
off the subjects i want to talk about
and to try to focus on
uh on me um
so i think my
i don't want to talk about it i i want
to talk
i've been driving i've been trying very
hard don't you
failures
throughout these
uh this session to talk about the things
that i that i care about now how much
consideration are you giving to the
prospect of your resignation uh i'm
happy to tell you that i'm getting on
with the job that i was elected to do
and that is what i'm gonna do so all
these problems are basically somebody
else's fault no i look i i think that
um i think it was
so who is one of these people who's left
who is responsible
i who should be held accountable i i am
responsible but i'm also responsible uh
bernard for delivering a huge manifesto
uh commitments uh that we made in 2019
many of which are now coming through uh
uh hugh asked about what are we doing uh
to make sure that we're we're taxing
electric vehicles properly there is
there is a colossal body of work uh that
we're we're engaged on right now uh we
are uniting and leveling up across the
country we have the biggest program of
infrastructure investment that we've had
for 100 years and i'm going to get on
with delivering on the
the program that we set out and on the
priorities of the people of this country
and i know that there will be plenty of
people who for whatever motive i want to
try to throw me off course uh by
turning it into a story about something
entirely different and i think
that it would be a fine thing
if we focused on the arguments between
us that are about policy and about the
agenda and what we are what we actually
uh love doing uh which is working hard
uh for our constituents and trying to
make their lives better
let's let's talk i mean we have we've
had some interesting exchanges
about uh how to control inflation
or uh or
or motor vehicles
those are the things that people are
interested in and that's what i'm
focused on
caroline notes
bullying and sexual
harassment are about a culture of power
have you just sat there and told us that
alcohol is an excuse not at all not at
all uh not at all is it i i made it
throwing us off the story by trying to
talk about alcohol instead of talking
about the culture that has underpinned
those behaviors not at all not at all i
i i you know i just i i observe that
some people seem to get very drunk but
you know
i i that in no way
minimizes the underlying uh pattern of
herbage well that's what you've just
done exactly
i don't think i i understand i i
vehemently disagree with that i hope
that you will reflect
that in the end
we're all dispensable
the welfare of the british people and
the security of the nation are
indispensable
and
if you are becoming an obstruction to
the achievement of those aims
i hope you will consider your position i
i i of course i would but i wanted you
to know
that my job is to get on and deliver on
those aims and that is what i was
elected will you resign if it is clear
that you do not have
the confidence of the majority of
conservative mps
you you're asking me i i love this
community
again to offer commentary today
that if you have lost the confidence of
your mps you will not seek a dissolution
you will stand aside and allow a
leadership election to take place so the
prime minister may take may center for
an alternative leader that's that's the
proper procedure isn't it what i'm going
to do is get on with it no i need to ask
you which way you're quite right where i
passionately i need you to answer this
question
and you're required to step down as
leader of the conservative party you
will not seek to dissolve parliament
well
this country needs them because we're
last thing there's this house but this
happens but i'm not going to step down
and the last thing this country needs
frankly is election because this house
on the country i think the the the risk
is the risk is uh that uh
people continue to focus on uh this type
of thing and i think that is a mistake
and how would it help get on with stable
how would it help the crisis in ukraine
and the cost of living crisis if we were
plunged into a general election that
nevertheless this is what this is your
i'd say it's your fault then i i think
you didn't let it out really of course i
resigned you've ruled it out i i i
the earliest date that i can see for a
general election
uh is in two years from now
or 2024 i think is the most likely date
for next election uh we have a huge
amount to deliver we're going to get on
and do it
and you'll resign if a vote of
confidence in the conservative party i
think
i think we're done it's carried out
otherwise you're staying if you're
asking you're asking me to comment on uh
on politics uh i think it's important
that we get on and deliver on our agenda
and that is what i was elected to do
well i think it's the understanding of
this committee you envisioned a general
election in 23 or 24 not before you'd
use it and if and if you're
if if you've lost the confidence of your
own mps and you cease to be leader of
the conservative party you will not
plunge this country into an unwanted
general election
i've i've been very clear with you i see
yes and whatever
for a general election now on the
country what we need is uh stable
government loving each other uh as
conservatives uh getting on to uh with
our with our priorities that is what we
need to do it's about it okay i love all
my colleagues of commons
thank you
thank you
so there we have it the prime minister
at the liaison committee a pretty
uncomfortable day this is turning out
for the prime minister insisting that he
sees no
reason why he should go refusing uh to
be drawn into his personal
political crisis but there is a greeting
party the story is developing here there
is a greeting party here of senior
cabinet members and they will be wanting
to talk to him and there is a meeting of
mps his own mps uh tonight at five
o'clock and if the cabinet members can't
talk him into going then the mps will
try to act themselves let's get the
latest beth rigby is here uh with us uh
so beth
this
group of cabinet ministers here what
will they be telling him mark this is
moving very quickly now since the prime
minister went into the liaison committee
they've been